a week later after we had that
conversation on his show and we
obviously talked about much more and I
even got him to say that if Cali brought
lockdowns back and mandates and
everything else that he actually would
move to Florida that's a pretty big
concession for the you know the the gold
standard of liberalism in America here
is uh Bill Maher on his show one week
later uh talking about the pandemic and
our reaction and all the subsequent
problems now we're getting some
information after a while we have time
for find out just how bad the collateral
damage has been uh here's just a few
cases the pandemic erased two decades of
progress in math and reading see right
away I got to say this pisses me off I
see these headlines all the time the
pandemic didn't do that the way we
handled the pandemic did that the
pandemic certainly was a thing
but let's not just say the pandemic
because it was not written in stone that
we had to handle it the way we did uh
ACT scores are the lowest in 30 years
um anxiety and depression way up the
body mass index uh increased doubled for
Kids 2 to 19. drug overdose overdose
deaths murders way up inflation at a
40-year high domestic violence increased
um oh and my favorite car crashes they
couldn't figure this out like we're way
way way up and there finally the I love
this this is the the expert said you
know what it is people just went [ __ ]
mental
yeah
they just went nuts they're like I'm
home the [ __ ] kids are here all the
time my stupid husband is here all the
time I'm just gonna take it out on the
highway and they did uh what you don't
have is the benefit of the alternative
scenarios to see how they would have
come out to be able to judge whether
what did happen was a lesser evil than
other options that would have unfolded
and so so suppose somebody actually we
do because other countries handled it
differently Sweden didn't handle it
differently some of the places with the
lowest vaccination rates turned out to
have the best results with really low
population densities well yes I mean yes
there are different factors there are
yes that matters yes of course you just
said you're going to elevator in New
York City like 15 people okay okay you
just you just said we can't make any
judgments because we don't live in an
alternative Universe where America
handled it differently and I'm saying
other places handled it differently that
does matter it all right
it's a legitimate I think it's a
legitimate conversation to have you
remember there was talk of of herd
immunity and how we get there at the
outset and people were shouted down for
even raising that Prospect I'm not the
scientist you are but in retrospection
down the idea that it might have escaped
from a lab right that was somehow racist
right as opposed to the some of you
believe that it came from the wet
markets you were a Democrat and people
came from a lab you were a republican
so that is good right it's good when
people and I know a lot of you and I I
when I talk about Bill Maher I always
get a lot of comments people are like
why are you still talking about him he's
never going to get there he voted for
all Democrats last time around but but
if someone like him talking about some
of this stuff getting to the truth
better late than never right because
he's supporting as far as I can tell
he's supporting still a guy like
avenuesome who is still for all of these
things or at least did all of these
things in the past right
um but him talking about it waking up
some people is good
[Music]